اعلنت الولايات المتحده تزويد اوكرانيا
بذخائر عنقوديه لاول مره منذ بدء الحرب
وهو ما وصفت روسيا التي شنت هجوما مضادا
في محور زابروجيا بانه دليل على فشل
الهجوم المضاد من ناحيتها تعاهدت كييف
بسعاده جميع اراضيها التي سيطرت عليها
روسيا بعد مرور خمس مئه يوم من الحرب التي
دعت انقره طرفيها لانهائ
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما الذي دفع واشنطن لتزويد
كياب ببخائر عنقوديه لاول مره منذ بدء
الحرب وما هي تاثيراته المحتمله على مسار
الحرب وما علاقته بتاكيد بايدن صعوبه
انضمام اوكرانيا الى حلف الناتو حاليا
وكيف ستتعامل موسكو مع هذا التطور وما هي
المتغيرات التي يمكن ان يفرضها على
استراتيجيتها لاداره المواجهات في جبهتي
جنوب اوكرانيا وشرقيها وما هي الانعكاسات
المحتمله لهذا التصيد على فرص التسويه
بالنظر للحراك التركي ومحاولات التوصل الى
ارضيه تنطلق منها مباحثات بين الطرفين
[موسيقى]
بعد خمس مئه يوم من حرب حصدت بحسب الامم
المتحده ارواحها تسعه الاف مدني اوكراني
وفي خطوه وصفه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بالصعبه وبالتزامن مع تاكيد بايدن عدم
استعداد اوكرانيا للانضمام الى حلف الناتو
في الوقت الراهن اعلنت واشنطن تزويد
اوكرانيا بذخائر عنقوديه لاول مره منذ بدا
الحرب
تواصل الولايات المتحده دعمها المستمر
لاوكرانيا باعلانها اليوم عن حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لتزويد قواتها بمزيد من
الذخائر والاسلحه والمعدات التي تحتاجها
للدفاع عن بلادها في وجه العدوان الروسي
حزمه المساعدات هذه تضم ذخائر اضافيه
لنظام باتريوت للدفاع الجوي وذخائر هايمرز
ومركبات برادلي وناقلات مدرعه وذخائر جويه
دقيقه
جدل يتزامن مع تطورات ميدانيه على الارض
اكدت روسيا انها صدت في اطارها هجمات
اوكرانيه على محاور عقد وشنت بدورها هجوما
مضادا على محور زابولوجيا بينما اكدت كييف
استعاده جزيره الافعى في البحر الاسود من
روسيا
واعتبرت ذلك دليلا على انها ستستعد كل
اراضيها
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
موسكو سردين ماركوز
عضو مجلس الدمى السابق ومدير معهد دراسه
السياسيه في موسكو من واشنطن ينضم الينا
السفير كورت فولكر السفير الامريكي السابق
لدى النيتو وينضم الينا من عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ارحب بكم جميعا وابدا معك في واشنطن
السفير كورس فولكر لماذا الان بعد مرور
خمس مئه يوم على حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
جاء هذا القرار
محقه كان ينبغي القيام بذلك في وقت مبكر
وربما كان له اثر اكثر لا اعتقد سبب هذا
التاخير هو لان اوكرانيا في مرحله تحاول
ان تخترق فيها الدفاعات
الروسيه لاستعاده اراضيها
ولتسريع هذه العمليه وتنظيف الخنادق من
الجنود
الروس هذه الذخيره ستكون مفيده جدا وهذا
ياتي في وقت
ان
انظمه هاي مارس
ليس فيها ما يكفي من الذخائر ايضا
لذلك هذا النوع من الذخائر هو مهم جدا
ويعوض ذلك هو كما تقول مهم جدا جدا عفوا
بحسبك ومفيد جدا ولكن ما الضمانات بانه
روسيا عفوا بانه اوكرانيا لن تستخدم هذه
الذخائر القنابل العنقوديه بشكل يستفز
روسيا
لا اعتقد ان استفزاز روسيا يحتاج اي
حسابات انها تهاجم اوكرانيا وترتكب جرائم
حرب
[موسيقى]
روسيا لا ينبغي ان نقلق من استفزاز روسيا
ينبغي ان نهتم بهزيمه روسيا
سيد
لا ينبغي ان نهتم بغضب روسيا او
باستفزازها لاننا في حرب يقول السفير كورس
فولكرم ما ردك على هذا الكلام
كان كنت اتمنى ان ارى هذا السيد السفير في
القيد تحت
تحت افعال وقصف هذه الصواريخ عندها كانت
تتحدث بطريقه اخرى لان الامريكيين سعيدين
بان الروسيين يقتلون بعضهم البعض لاننا
نعلم ان 75 من الاوكرانيين هم روس في
الواقع وهذه هي الارقام الموضوعيه ان
اللغه الروسيه هي اللغه الاساسيه ل75 من
مواطنين اوكرانيا لذلك توصيل هذه الاسلحه
العنقوديه لاوكرانيا هو دليل على ان
واشنطن هي قاتله وهم قتل يريدون ان يقوم
الروس بقتل بعضهم البعض هذا اولا الشيء
الثاني حتى تفهمون جيدا ما هي فعاليه هذه
الاسلحه نعم هذه اسلحه فعاله
وهذه تقريبا ربع الصاروخ النووي التكتيكي
هذا يعني ان هذا استخدام لاسلحه تكتيكيه
نوويه جزئيا وهذا بالنسبه لنا يعني انه في
لحظه من اللحظات واشنطن سوف تقوم بتقديم
لاوكرانيا اسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه وسوف تبدا
حرب نوويه وعندها سوف تضطر روسيا للرد على
استخدام هذه الاسلحه التي تعتبر اسلحه
دمار شامل اي الذخيره العنقوديه ونحن سوف
نضطر لاستخدام اسلحه لم يسبق لنا
استخدامها لا نريد التصعيد وروسيا لا تريد
التصعيد روسيا تريد ان تتوقف عن العمليات
العسكريه فورا ولكن على شرط ان اوكرانيا
سوف تكون حياديه وان اله سوف تتغير وان
اللغه الروسيه التي تعتبر لغه 75% من
الاوكرانيين لن تكن محظوره في اوكرانيا
تخيلي اذا قام احد بمنع اللغه العربيه في
مصر او في السعوديه اذا ما قام احد بمنع
اللغه العربيه في السعوديه بالطبع هذا سوف
يكون ضد الديمقراطيه والحريه الشيء الثالث
هو استخدام
الذخيره العنقوديه والقذائف العنقوديه هي
هذا قرار من واشنطن لماذا لانهم قد
استنفذوا جميع الذخيره التي تستخدم
للمدفعيه العاديه وهذا يعني ان الحرب كانت
فعاله اكثر من اي توقعات وهذا يعني ان
المستودعات في فرنسا والمانيا وبريطانيا
وفي حتى مستودعات امريكا ان الذخيره هنا
قد استنفذت ولق خسروا كل الصواريخ
والذخيره
175 ملي متر وهذا يعني انها جريمه من طرف
بايدن وانا اتمنى ان يحاكم بايضا على هذه
الجرائم الحربيه طيب اذا كانت هذه الاسلحه
كما يصفها الان سيركي ماركوب بانها اسلحه
تكتيكيه خطيره وما الذي يمنع واشنطن كما
يقول ان تقدم في المستقبل اسلحه نوويه
وساعتها سنرد كما قال في روسيا باسلحه
نوويه يعني دخلنا في حرب نوويه الان خطوره
هذه الاسلحه ما مدى خطورتها وما الذي يمكن
ان تغيره في او دخوله على الخط ما الذي
يغيره على المعادله الحاليه
يعني لا انا لا اتفق مع ضيفك الكريم عندما
اعتبرها جزء من السلاح النووي التكتيكي لا
هذا سلاح تقليدي حتى للاسف هي لا تخترق
القانون الدولي انا هنا اتحدث في المقاربه
عسكريه قانونيه يعني ممنوعه في كثير من
الدول القنابل العقوديه اتفق اتفاقي
اتفاقيه
2008 وافق على هذه الاتفاقيه 111 دوله
ووافقوا على منع الانتاج ومنع التخزين
ومنع الاستخدام وتدمير المخزونات خلال
ثمان سنوات هذا نعم حدث لكن حسب التوصيف
القانوني لا تعتبر جريمه حرب لماذا
لان المحاسبه ليست على نوع المقذوف
المحاسبه على طبيعه الهدف الذي يتم
استهدافه اذا استخدمت ضد المدنيين تعتبر
جريمه حرب اذا استخدمت ضد مواقع عسكريه تع
سلاح تقليدي الان ما هي الاثار الناتجه
لديها لها فاعليه هذه تختلف
من حيث الحجم وعدد القنيبلات الداخليه حسب
طريقه
ما هي وسيله القذف هل هي من حاويات من
الطائرات هل هي من راجمات الصواريخ هل هي
من مدافع هاوزر في اكبر الحالات تصل الى
الحاضر الواحده بها تقريبا اربع مئه قنبله
صغيره
تغطي مساحه والمساحه مرتبطه
بعلو نقطه التفجير التي تبدا من مئه متر
وتنتهي بالف متر اذا كانت على ارتفاع 1000
متر تكون اقصى مساحه هي
200 عرض المنطقه ب 400 متر طول المنطقه اي
تقريبا ثلاث اضعاف مساحه ملعب القدم
المشكله تكمن في
طريقه التفجير لانها ثلاث انواع النوع
الاول
توقيتي يتم تفجيره في الجو وينفجر الى 300
شظيه النوع الاخر صادم ينفجر لحظه
الاصطدام ويحتاج الى ارض صلبه النوع
بعد الاصطدام يكون لفيوز تاخيري
سلبيات كبيره جدا تلوث الارض تمنع استخدام
الارض طريقه الاستخدام مهمه
وهنا سفير كوردف
هل
لدى واشنطن ضمانات بان كيف سوف تستخدم هذه
الاسلحه بشكل عقلاني لانه هناك رد فعل
روسيا على لسان ماريا خروف الناطقه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه تقول واشنطن تدرك ان لا
قيمه لوعود كييف باستخدام هذا السلاح يعني
القنابل العنقوديه
بعنايه وبمسؤوليه
لا معنى للتفكير في ان اوكرانيا سوف
تقصف
مدنيها هي تستخدمها لحمايه مدنيه
وضد القوات الروسيه التي تهاجم اوكرانيا
واعتقد انه سيكون غير منطقيا ابدا ان نفكر
بان اوكرانيا ستستخدمها ضد المدنيين
الاوكرانيين بعض الامور التي قالها السيد
ماركوف ينبغي تصحيحها اولا
روسيا تستخدم
الذخائر العنقوديه في اوكرانيا
وليس هذا مماثلا لاستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه
روسيا فقط هددت باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه وقد حضرتها دول اخرى منها الهند
والصين والمتحده بين ذلك سيكون كارثيا
للقوات الروسيه ولا احد يريد ان يرى تلك
الاسلحه تستخدم
والولايات المتحده
ان امريكا تريد ان ترى الاوكرانيين
والروسيا تحاربون بالعكس روسيا هي التي
بدات هذه الحرب ولا احد يريد ان يرى حربا
اوكرانيا لا تريد حربا الولايات المتحده
فقط روسه التي تريد الحرب
يعني شاهدت كتعوز راسك عندما كان يتحدث
بان روسيا ايضا تستخدم هذا النوع من
الاسلحه
ما ردك
ان هذا كذب وليس حقيقه هذا كل ما استطيع
ان اقوله هذه بروباندا كاذبه للاسف ما
تحدث بها الضيف وهذا شيء مستمر وهذه
تكنولوجيا
الامريكيه ومن وجهه نظرنا ليس هناك اي حرب
بين
روسيا واوكرانيا بل ان اوكرانيا هي محتله
سياسيا من الولايات المتحده والولايات
المتحده هي من
تدير حرب ضد روسيا بايدي
اوكرانيه و واشنطن تستخدم هذه التكنولوجيه
دمروا خطوط الغاز في
اتهموا روسيا ثم قاموا بتنظيم مجزره في
بوتشا
وهناك قامت القوات الاوكرانيه بقتل
المواطنين الاوكران ثم اتهموا الروس فجروا
سد كخوفكا
وحتى وصل الجنون منهم واعذروني على هذا
الحديث قالوا ان روسيا هي من تقصف المحطه
الذريه التي تقع تحت السيطره الروسيه لعام
كامل ويقولون اننا نريد ان نفجر المحطه
الذريه في التي تقع تحت سيطرتنا نحن اي
شخص عاقل ممكن ان يصدق هذا هذه
الواضحه
وهذه وهذا سيناريو متكرر يقوم بجرائم
حربيه ضد الانسانيه بالايدي الاوكرانيه ثم
يتهموا بها روسيا
في العالم كله العالم
كلها يحدث الولايات هي التي افتعلت هذه
الحرب ولدي سؤال للضيف هل ممكن ان تبحث في
جوجل هناك خمسه وسبعين
بالمئه في جوجل البحث في جوجل باللغه
الروسيه من الاراضي الاوكرانيه اذا 75% من
المواطنين الاوكران هم روس ويمنعوهم من
الحديث باللغه الروسيه في الدواء الرسميه
وفي الاعلام وفي المدارس بل تتخيل القاعه
العربيه
ليس هذا موضوع ليس هذا موضوع الحلقه لكن
روسيا اذا كل هذا ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله
ما هو رد الفعل الروسي المتوقع اذا ازاء
هذه الخطوه
سوف نقوم باستخدام الاسلحه العنقوديه ايضا
كرد على هذا للاسف نقوم بكل شيء حتى لا
يكون هناك تصعيد ولكن عندما يقوم عدونا
الولايات المتحده والسيد بايدن
المذنبين ببدايه هذه الحرب عندما يعلنوا
انها عدونا سوف يستخدم الاسلحه العنقوديه
اذا سوف نضطر لاستخدامها لاستخدامها ايضا
يستخدموا الاسلحه العقوديه سنستخدم نحن
ايضا الاسلحه العنقوديه يدخلنا في اي
دائره
يعني الان
تقارير هيوما رايت اكثر من تقرير اثبت ان
روسيا منذ بدايه الحرب استخدمت القنابل
العنقوديه وان اوكرانيا استخدمتها ثلاث
مرات بالتالي كلا الجانبين استخدم القنابل
العنقوديه في هذه الحرب لكن الاختلاف على
حول عدد المرات التي تم استخدامها من قبل
اي من طرفي الصراع هذه القنابل اول من
استخدمها
1943 الاتحاد السوفيتي ضد القوات النازيه
الالمانيه واستخدمتها المانيا وبدا
استخدامها واستخدمتها 28 دوله في معظم
الحروب وتحديدا في افغانستان استخدمتها
امريكا واستخدمتها روسيا في ناغورنو
كاراباخ استخدمتها ارمينيا واذربيجان
استخدمتها اسرائيل في
1982 وال 2006 فبالتالي هي ليست سلاحا
طارئا ولا جديدا واستقدم من قبل ثمانيه
وعشرين دوله في الحروب السابقه خلال
العقود الماضيه الان هل الاستخدامها من
كلا الجانبين هو تعقيد للحرب هو توسيع
لدائره الصراع وتعمق في استخدام او افراط
في استخدام ادوات القتل لكن هي تقدم خدمه
اضافيه ونوعيه للجانب الاوكراني في الفتره
الحاليه لماذا لانها الهجوم المضاد تباطا
لم يحقق اهدافه المقرره بسبب شبكه
التحصينات فهنا استخدامها يقدم خدمه
للقوات الاوكرانيه يضاف الى ذلك اشار احد
ضيوفك الى
نفاذ او قرب نفاذ المخزونات واود ان اقول
الاتي
دقيقتين سيد
كورد فوكر اذا كان هذا يقدم فعلا خدمه
عسكريه على الارض كبيره جدا لاكييف ونحن
تابعنا طبعا تسريبات الاسبوع الماضي
للواشنطن بوست التي قالت فيها ان اوكرانيا
لديها خطه لتحقيق انتصارات سوف تجبر روسيا
نهايه هذه السنه على الجلوس الى طاوله
المفاوضات هل هذا التصعيد يدخل ضمن هذه
الخطه برايك
اعتقد انه اسمه الدفاع عن النفس
واوكرانيا ترى ما تفعله روسيا للمدنيين في
الاراضي التي تحتلها ولا تريد ان تترك تلك
الاراضي محتله من الروس هي تعمل على ان
تخترق
الدفاعات
الروسيه لكي تستعيد اراضيها بما في ذلك
القرم هذا ليس تصعيدا هذا دفاعا عن النفس
في انه يعني واشنطن تدعم
الذخائر العنقوديه ولكن في نفس الوقت
بايضا يقول اوكرانيا ليست مهيئه بعد
للانضمام الى حلف الناتو كيف نفهم هذه
المفارقه
نعم
اعتقد ان ما يقلق بشانه الرئيس بايدن هو
ان يوضح للجميع ان هذه ليست حربا من حلف
الناتو لروسيا وذلك ما تقوله روسيا وسيد
ماركوف
الولايات المتحده ليست في حرب ضد روسيا
هذه حرب روسيه ضد اوكرانيا والرئيس يوضح
من ان الامر لا يتعلق بحلف الناتو
بالروسيه وهي وهجمتها على اوكرانيا السيد
ماركوب يقول ان 75% من الاوكرانيين
يتحدثون الروسيه كلغه اولى وهي مبالغه
ولكن هذه
الاستراليون يتحدثون الانجليزيه وكذلك
الامريكيون وهذا لا يعني انهم جزء من
المملكه المتحده
موسكو الان اذا هذا التطور
انه بالنسبه للاسلحه العنقوديه ليس هناك
خيارات كثيره
حتى الان لم تستخدم روسيا الاسلحه
العنقوديه ولن تقوم بهذا ولكن اذا ظهرت
هذه الاسلحه على الجبهات واذا قام عدونا
بايدن بتوصيل هذه الاسلحه لخدمته الاوكران
واذا قدم الاوامر ان تستخدم
القذائف العنقوديه ضد روسيا عندها سوف
تضطر روسيا لاستخدام هذه الاسلحه ايضا
ولكن بالنسبه لنا المشكله ان هذا الشعب
البرنامج اعتذر لمقاطعتك سيد ماركوب
لانتهاء وقت البرنامج شكرا جزيلا لك
عضو مجلس ادوم السابق ومدير مع هذا دراسات
السياسيه في موسكو ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا من
واشنطن السفير كورت فولكر السفير
الامريكيه السابق لدى النايتو ونشكر ضيفنا
من عمان اللواء فايزه الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي
الى هنا تنتهي مشاهدينا هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]